la région
Île-de-France a adopté en septembre
dernier son schéma régional éolien qui
estime que 100 à 180 éoliennes pourrait
être implantés d'ici à 2020 qu'en
pensent les associations locales nous
donnons ce soir la parole à Yvelines
environnement François Jeanneret bonsoir
pour vous les éoliennes en Île-de-France
dans le département des Yvelines c'est
oui ou c'est non
c'est plutôt non pour différentes
raisons d'abord ce dossier qui nous a
été communiqué enfin soumis si vous
voulez pour études elle a été pendant
l'été ce qui n'est pas très simple quand
on vous donne un dossier autour du 14
juillet et que vous devez rendre votre
copie pour le 20 septembre c'est un peu
juste si vous me permettez sur un
dossier d'une telle importance donc déjà
premier petit bémol et deuxième bémol
nous sommes très heureux que l'on étudie
l'éolien car pour notre association pour
Yvelines environnement nous souhaitons
avant tout que soit étudié
toutes les ce qui peut se faire si vous
voulez entendre solaire quand quand
géothermie toutes les possibilités qui
feront qu'on le réduira demain le besoin
de centrale nucléaire pour vous vous
n'êtes pas contre l'association n'est
pas contre l'éolien mais vous voulez
plus de garantie être sur que
l'investissement qui sera fait sera
rentable en tout cas bien sûr que ça ne
va pas te dénaturer non plus le paysage
ça fait partie des données importantes
pour vous capital capital d'abord une
absence totale dans ce dossier deux
éléments qui nous sommes essentiels
c'est l'insertion dans le paysage or je
suis désolé vous connaissez une éolienne
c'est un mât avec des grandes pales
quand il tourne effectivement les palmes
on les voit moins mais ce sont à ce
moment-là des pièges à oiseaux car les
oiseaux migrateurs ne les voient pas et
quand elles sont à la race un impact
effectivement important dans le paysage
surtout si elles sont regroupées
deuxième point essentiel une éolienne ça
ne fonctionne pas tout le temps alors
c'est une vérité de la Pallice de dire
que il faut du vent oui c'est vrai mais
si vous voulez il y a de
grands d'autres éléments si vous les
grands froids elles fonctionnent pas
trop de chaleur elle ne fonctionne pas
non plus donc si vous voulez le
rendement n'est pas constant
nous n'avons pas eu si vous voulez
compte tenu de ces éléments climatiques
qui sont pour nous extrêmement
importants nous n'avons pas eu si vous
voulez de schéma indiquant quel serait
la production de ces éoliennes deuxième
point
dans la mesure où ces éoliennes sont
implantées et qu'elle ratio par rapport
à la distribution d'électricité actuelle
de combien cela va-t-il diminuer la
consommation actuelle aucun élément ce
point est beaucoup de doutes sur ce sur
ce rapport on l'entend en tout cas de
votre côté vous émettez beaucoup de
réserves
c'est combien ça coûte et je crois que
une époque où ma foi l'argent ne coule
pas à flot hélas où nous devons faire
des économies nous n'avons aucun élément
sur le coût d'une éolienne le coût de
son fonctionnement quid ensuite quand
une éolienne est hors d'usage et il peut
leur arriver d'être en panne tellement
recyclé recycler parce que ces éoliennes
pour permettre si vous voulez au vent de
les faire tourner elles ont besoin d'un
socle qui est extrêmement important et
il y a donc si vous voulez en béton en
pied de ses éoliennes un impact qui est
très fort sur la terre où elles sont
implantées dans les éoliennes en tout
cas ce n'est pas forcément pour demain
ce schéma qui était adopté par la Région
Île-de-France qui pourrait permettre de
voir le jour à 180 éoliennes ce n'est
qu'un schéma indicatif ce sont des zones
des zones qui seraient plus favorables
que d'autres pour accueillir les
éoliennes pour faire le point reportage
d'Anthony Reich
les Yvelinois doivent se préparer les
éoliennes vont pousser à côté de leur
maison d'ici à 2020 la consultation du
SRE francilien le schéma régional éolien
pour l'Île-de-France vient de se
terminer ce plan définit les zones
favorables au développement de l'énergie
éolienne en clair le sr.e est une sorte
de nomenclature pour les collectivités
locales ce seront aux élus locaux de
mettre en place des projets de
construction de parc éolien sur ces
zones
des définit pas les projets éoliens les
définis à l'échelle régionale le
territoire sur lesquels pourront être
portés des projets la nuance est subtile
mais elle est importante puisque les
projets liens très concrètement seront
portés à l'initiative des maires des
différentes communes du territoire
située en zone favorable ou des
présidents d'intercommunalité situé dans
les zones favorables du schéma régional
éolien sur l'Île-de-France 671 villes
sont concernés dont 109 communes dans
les Yvelines cette carte montre que dans
le département 3 zones ont été
sélectionnées pour l'implantation
d'éoliennes au sud du département sur la
plaine d'Ablis à l'ouest près de Houdan
et au sud de Mantes-la-Jolie
l'association Yvelines environnement
redoute pourtant une facture salée pour
le consommateur aucune inquiétude à
avoir pour le conseil régional la
deuxième
énergie avant celle qui arrive
tout de suite
donc vous êtes aujourd'hui sur une
énergie renouvelable qui est compétitive
par rapport à des énergies
conventionnelles voire même qu'ils sont
voire même une énergie qui est située en
dessous du coût de production des
énergies fossiles ou des énergies
physiques classiques mais l'association
Yvelines environnement s'inquiète aussi
du danger sur la faune et le paysage le
plan assure qu'aucune éolienne ne serait
implantée par exemple à moins de 500
mètres d'habitation à l'heure actuelle
il faut aller à Guitrancourt pour
trouver la seule éolienne du département
d'ici à 2020 100 à 180 éoliennes
devraient être installés dans la région
voilà pour l'instant ce n'est qu'un
schéma que des études pour
éventuellement potentiellement installer
ces éoliennes et chaque projet devrait
donner lieu à une étude d'impact une
enquête publique un permis de construire
ça suffit à vous rassurer ou pas pas
vraiment pas vraiment parce que nous
sommes d'abord étonnés dans certaines
communes vous l'évoquiez tout à l'heure
dans le mantoir ou dans le sud-yvelines
des dépôts de permis de construire ont
été déposés auprès des municipalités
antérieurement à la signature de ce
document donc déjà il y a là une petite
ambiguïté
les informations avaient filtrées mais
il est certain que il y a eu des permis
de construire de déposer antérieurement
à la signature de ce document et puis
deuxième point vous savez que les
agriculteurs sont tout à fait opposés
puisque malheureusement dans la région
Île-de-France le bâti est important et
les espaces sont souvent ou agricoles ou
boisé ce qui reste disponible et les
agriculteurs ont pris position de façon
très ferme contre et puis dans d'autres
secteurs comme par exemple la plaine de
Versailles où il y avait un projet
éolien qui n'est pas récent puisqu'il
date de 2009 là aussi si vous voulez les
associations comme les élus ont pris
très fermement position contre alors
nous avons quand même obtenu quelque
chose parce que justement en parlant de
la plaine de Versailles le domaine de
Versailles classe monument historique
classé au Patrimoine Mondial à travers
les protections de l'ONU et nous avons
obtenu et il n'y avait aucune protection
particulière si vous voulez pour les
sites classés ou ces sites
particulièrement sensibles et nous avons
obtenu que dans ce document soit évoquer
la question de non constructibilité de
l'éolien dans les sites notamment
inscrits au Patrimoine mondial donc on a
déjà obtenu un petit quelque chose
nous espérons pas on va donner la parole
à présent aux Yvelines savoir s'ils sont
pour ou contre l'éolien vos réponses
moi je suis pour je suis pour trouver
des nouvelles énergies et l'éolienne à
partir du moment où respecte un peu la
distance des habitations je trouve ça
moi plutôt élégant parce que je trouve
que ça fait pas plus moche que les
poteaux électriques et puis que voilà
c'est l'avenir là on est à la recherche
de nouvelles énergies donc il faut
développer ce qui peut nous en fait dans
l'avenir
prendre le relais sur le sur l'énergie
qui va disparaître plutôt pour parce que
ça semble écologique et que je dirais il
y a quand même de grands espaces en
France et des zones très ventées qui
peuvent produire de l'énergie un bon
compte je suis moyennement pour enfin
disons que je pense que la l'avenir de
l'éolienne c'est surtout le marin
que le qu'il faut essayer de joindre ce
que j'appelle l'utile à l'agréable à
savoir les conséquences un peu au niveau
de la pêche etc et aussi le fait de
pouvoir avoir une diversification de nos
énergies sachant que pour moi le
nucléaire et la source principale et que
liens c'est une petite contribution qui
s'est pas avec ça qu'on arrivera à
régler le problème
mettre les éoliennes en pleine mer c'est
plutôt la bonne solution
pourquoi pas pourquoi pas mais il y a
aussi toute la circulation des bateaux
qui en dépendent il y a aussi la force
de la mer il y a eu cette très ancienne
marémotrice de Dinard pourquoi pas je
pense que si vous voulez aujourd'hui il
est très important de pouvoir faire une
recherche sur l'ensemble de ces éléments
qui permettront de main je dis la
diminution du nucléaire si la France est
en retard l'Île-de-France principalement
retard sur ses éoliennes il vaut mieux
attendre en tout cas de sûr des
implantations c'est votre position je
crois que pour le moment c'est un
dossier qui n'est pas encore si vous me
le permettez tout à fait au point et je
pense qu'il y a une grande information
du public qu'il serait important de ce
que vous faites fortement ce soir à
faire parce que je pense que le grand
public ne sépare réellement ce qu'est
l'éolien une toute dernière question en
janvier 2012 le magazine L'Express vous
classez parmi les 15 personnalités les
plus influentes sur Versailles et sa
région est-ce que ça va vous servir pour
ce dossier pour vous faire entendre vous
avez déjà commencé à faire jouer les
réseaux oui tout à fait oui bien sûr
puisque vous savez nous avons obtenu les
associations nationales avec lesquelles
nous sommes liés nous avons évoqué ce
point ensemble et elles ont décidé de
consigner vous en avez la liste maison
paysanne de France les VMF l'Association
pour la protection des sites et des
paysages la Demeure Historique et ces
associations ont décidé elles aussi
d'écrire elle au Premier ministre en
tant qu'association nationale est
reconnue d'utilité publique pour si vous
voulez s'inquiéter aussi de des
questions que nous nous posons tous
concernant l'éolien merci François Janet
doit être venu sur ce plateau présidente
d'Yvelines environnement 180 éoliennes
éventuellement en Île-de-France mais ça
n'est pas pour demain à vous entendre
merci d'être venu sur le plateau la
suite du 7 8 de ce 18 octobre avec
marie-élodie Royer une créatrice de mode
qui va ouvrir son atelier à
Voisins-le-Bretonneux pour des portes
ouvertes ce sera le face à face de cette
édition et juste après la chronique écho
avec Alice Gastine et puis politique
avec Jean-Frédéric Poisson est député de
la dixième circonscription des Yvelines
il va nous expliquer pourquoi elle
soutient à Jean-François Copé elle met
aussi pourquoi il s'oppose au mariage
pour tous un mariage pour tous
d'ailleurs dont l'examen parlait députés
va apprendre du retard éventuellement 4
semaines ça a été annoncé aujourd'hui
plus de détails tout à l'heure pour
l'instant retour sur le départ surprise
de Sylvie Faucheux l'actuel présidente
du pôle de recherche Université Paris
Grand Ouest elle a été nommée rectrice
de l'académie de Dijon elle prendra son
poste dé ce vendredi Catherine zulato et
Anthony Rech
ce jeudi matin dans l'amphi Condorcet de
l'Université de Versailles Saint-Quentin
ces étudiants anglophones écoutent les
explications de Sylvie Faucheux ils ne
savent pas qu'il s'agit de sa dernière
conférence en tant que présidente du
presse Université Paris Grand Ouest s'il
lui Faucheux a été nommé mercredi
rectrice de l'académie de Dijon pour une
prise de fonction dès ce vendredi une
nomination Express apprise par sms je
suis très heureuse je suis très fier
qu'on a dépensé à moi et donc c'est un
défi important de sur un nouveau
territoire donc voilà donc c'était une
surprise mais de belle surprise faut
s'organiser vite parce que même au
niveau de la au niveau professionnel
bien sûr je dirais que j'ai pas chopé
cette nuit pour essayer de tirer au
clair tous les dossiers faire aussi une
passation de mes dossiers mais aussi au
niveau de la vie privée c'est aussi
d'organisation très rapide
une organisation très rapide à Sylvie
Faucheux et depuis juillet 2012 la
présidente du pôle de recherche est
enseignement supérieur Université Paris
Grand Ouest la semaine dernière elle
présidait une conférence inaugurante on
peut dire que le presse est sur les
rails il y a des projets qui sont lancés
il y a des groupes de travail il y a un
vrai soutien de la part des
collectivités territoriales l'ensemble
des établissements semblaient dans le
même sens donc bon je pense que ça
arrive à un moment où finalement
peut-être les nouvelles équipes des deux
présidents des deux universités
fondatrices vont pouvoir insuffler à ce
presse ce qu'il souhaite une belle
poursuite de parcours pour celles qui a
obtenu son doctorat en sciences
économiques en 90 en 2002 il lui fauche
devient président de l'université de
Versailles Saint-Quentin elle le restera
pendant 10 ans marquant de son empreinte
dynamique le développement de la faculté
dont on vient de célébrer les 20 ans et
qui compte aujourd'hui 16 000 étudiants
je sais pas s'il y a une méthode c'est
d'abord je crois que je suis quelqu'un
d'assez enthousiaste donc
je m'en pardonne un dossier je le fais
avec passion bah je crois que si ça
permet d'entraîner les équipes derrière
et je bénéficie toujours en fait des
équipes qui qui ne regardent ni leur
temps ni leur énergie
Sylvie Fauchon ne quittera pas tout à
fait le département elle s'installera la
semaine à Dijon avant de revenir le
week-end dans les Yvelines où elle
réside elle demeure chercheur rattaché à
son laboratoire 5 continents